hey guys it's Tuesday I think I can't be
sure the jet lag is really starting to
set in how might you say I'm Dan and
this is your GES news roundup
[Music]
first up Blizzard has commissioned a
bunch of street artists to make ps4 and
Xbox one controllers are based on
overwatch and man they are delightful I
mean check out this lucio one ah so nice
buzz it worked with attitude a European
design firm on the ultra limited edition
controllers each controller is
individually numbered and can only be
acquired through giveaways in Europe per
48 controllers 24 for each platform were
designed by famous street artists let us
know which one is your favorite in that
comment box if you wish you could play
more video games for none of your
dollars battleborn is going to help you
out as their multiplayer has become free
o
free the best price 2k and gearbox
revealed a free version of hero shooter
battle born where players can access a
rotating group of six heroes out of the
30 total and battle it out with no limit
or level caps you'll have access to all
the gameplay modes and maps and
progression for each character is
permanent so when they pop back into
rotation you'll be able to continue with
them from where you left off
if you've ever put down a multiplayer
game never to return because you were
squashed by veteran players you'll be
happy to hear that newcomers are grouped
so up until you reach rank 20 you'll be
in the novice cube where you'll
hopefully kick a decent amount of but if
you already bought battleborn
2k haven't forgotten you as you'll have
been granted the founders bonus which
gets you a bunch of free bonuses like
in-game currency and flip Nintendo drop
the news today that you'll soon be able
to play pokken tournament on your switch
funnily enough Jess I've been poking my
switch ever since it came out thanks to
its touchscreen up top if you missed the
news early this morning Nintendo held an
eight-minute pokemon direct that dropped
a few exciting polka tidbits including
the news that pokken tournament is
coming to nintendo switch the fighting
game originally came out on Wii U so
chances are you didn't play it but the
new version called pokken tournament DX
is coming to Nintendo's new console on
September 22nd DX will include five new
Pokemon
Raye sizzle and paulien roller gunk and
decidua 3v3 battles and online ranked
play as well as friendly and group
matches all 16 characters from the
original version are included and a
playable demo of the switch version will
be available at e3 next week some of the
games online features will require paid
membership to the switches online
service but that won't be until 2018 if
it's a more traditional perk of my
experience you're after new Tendo also
revealed that pokemon gold and silver
will arrive on the 3ds Virtual Console
on September 22
much like the Virtual Console versions
of pokemon red blue and yellow gold and
silver will feature local wireless
connectivity the games will also be
compatible with the Pokemon bank but
lets you transfer your collection of
monsters to Sun and Moon and while we're
talking about Sun and Moon they also
announced pokemon ultra sun and moon oh
yeah there's more the new ultra versions
will have an alternate story and feature
new pokemon as well as new features that
will allow you to enjoy your adventure
even more what does that mean not sure
yet the games are out on 3ds come
November 17 so be sure to subscribe to
us so as soon as we know you do - that
is everything we've got for you today
don't forget to grab the games but now
app which is free on iOS and Android so
make sure you stay up to date on all the
news heading up to e3 and beyond we'll
see you tomorrow